hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well what all of you
care about
okay so two really important elements
consider their appeals make sacrifices
okay what else what else what else is
going into caring for some sort of
feelings towards this could be positive
or negative I care about you and you're
doing badly I feel a negative emotion
like pity or sadness or something like
that
that's what it means to have compassion
if you're doing well let me know when we
look at Arizona leader he's gonna talk
about friendship he says friends sharing
each other's misfortunes and in their
joys it's your birthday
hey I can't because it's your birthday
in your benevolences like this okay so
this is a good anything else we want to
throw in here anything we left out or
for understanding just a basic idea of
care alright so we want to say that the
ethics of care is amol theory then we're
saying something like here is quiet were
you're not a good person where you're
not doing the right thing it's almost
like you know the opposite of [ __ ] isn't
it for [ __ ] if your emotions were
involved that's not a good thing doesn't
anything world value this would be
saying unless your functions are
involved and you have some of these
other things like being willing to
sacrifice for the other person you're
not really a good person
yeah we'll be doing the right thing so
you know my being good to you because I
just want you to think I'm a small guy
and give me good ratings would not give
a wrong thing might being good to you as
students because I care about your
well-being and how you feel and that
sort of thing that would make me a good
person so one of the problems one of the
complaints that you can make about this
is you're required to people feel a
certain way in order to be good people
does that strike does that seem to have
any problems to it what if you don't
feel that was it mean you're a bad
person or automatically so like it says
this is the bill Kouga is making some
complaints he says benevolence actives
or another care valorizes a certain set
of non moral values or psychological
traits it puts a premium on possessing a
certain kind of personality specifically
it kind to get caring it that's a big
problem isn't it what if you're not a
caring person don't we kind of differ
some of us are more empathetic more
involved with other people's feelings
well there's not so much well this is
the way you understand ethics of care
that you don't have those feelings
you're not a good person you should try
to cultivate those feelings you kind of
get that impression sometimes
compassion don't you so Gilligan has a
response to this but it's not a complete
response
Gilligan says care is a preference for
relating others closely for getting into
each other's and colleges to share fears
concerns vulnerabilities when
confronting moral issues it's also a
preference for harmonious
non-competitive feelings and a
cooperative spirited relating and
commitment to making relationships last
by working on them in nurturing them but
then Puka says this is just a capacity
for psychological relatedness and some
people have more of this and some people
will have Lutz
so for Gilligan to make this into a
moral imperative is making people
responsible for their feelings
does that make you worry feel a bit
uncomfortable you don't know the right
feelings according to this moral theory
there would be something wrong does that
say that you you know associate you have
to be wrong of course you just don't
have to have this you know caring about
relationships and the willingness of
sacrificed not going a little bit
further if we buy this notion that men
are by their natures or you know whether
its environment or genetics or something
like that less caring and women are more
caring with the ethics of care
automatically replacing men into a
position where they've got to be lesser
you know moral beings or you know
consider you know women who don't fit
the sort of societal norms they say I
want career I'm just driven by that
would they be less moral people because
they don't have that psychological trait
so that that's that's a real worry to
other things that come up
but never once ethics or ethics of care
this pooping again does not take serious
seriously the existence of mean nasty
cruel hard-hearted hateful or abusive
individuals I think sometimes when
people have this kind of mindset that's
like the ethics of care that does tend
to be the case
people generally it's not the other
things who cares more like the ethics of
niceness everyone want to be nice to
each other why can't everybody get along
and just be nice nice is not really a
moral value good is a moral value true
is a moral value of justice and moral
value nice is just sort of like icing on
the cake it's not that satisfying by
itself how many of you ever assume
though that playing into the woods it's
a musical
and there's that who's that who's the
moral voice you don't realize that the
first act that you realize that the
second act who's the character who
actually knows the Baker know it's not
the Baker know the narrator's just
telling the story
who's the moral voice no so the least
likely from the first act personally
think is is the the bad guy in the first
act the witch and the witch against the
speech where she actually tells the
characters
nice is not good nice is not just nice
as a suitable data by requiring
everybody to be nice you make everybody
vulnerable to like you know that nasty
cruel hard-hearted hateful or abusive
individuals do these people exist
who's gonna close them the nice person
or the just person or the good person
right adjuster the good person because
they actually have some some convictions
they are able to judge would you you
know would it be a good idea for you to
actually consider the feelings
who's a complete bastard is that what
ethics of care would require you to do
how about we not not if it's something
that actually makes sense he goes a
little bit further he says third and
finally benevolence ethics demands too
much in the way of self-sacrifice
we definitely thinks of care what you
mean to mention away of self-sacrifice
Oh what are you guys think about that
with what we've said so far to be caring
means considering other people's
feelings making some sacrifices allowing
other people to affect your decisions
and feeling a certain way towards them
this major sacrifice or the limits are
their property limits to that ethics of
a character recognized or once you say
well you got to care about other people
is it anything governess
that's that's a good point that you are
another person so you want to have as
much care at least towards yourself as
you do towards other people I think a
lot of the ethics of care people think
that the challenge for women traditional
I'm very suspicious of this one because
I see a lot of when it comes to class
things and it doesn't matter whether
particularly this one of the other
criticisms talks about being forced to
smile all the time how many of you work
retail before how many do work in
restaurants do or other places where
love you I mean if you work at the back
of the restaurant as well but if you're
a waiter right and people act like jerks
plates it yeah that's the same way in
retail sales
even though office if somebody didn't
had office jobs don't use a lot of times
have to put out and kind of a happy face
he's employer you're not really that
happy and be nurturing and get along
with everybody and inside you think and
contradict these people driving me nuts
right that many islands the point that
they're making in that is that having to
put on that mask eventually makes it
hard to be genuinely happy think there's
a problem not only for women but also
for a lot of men at least the society
I've experienced that probably
teachings
smile
so these worries about required care it
seems to be this seems to be saying
there's an equation woman caring that's
good that that leads to some problems
is this really a set of you know knock
down this can't possibly be a good wall
theory criticisms that I don't think
these are these point towards some of
the limits